in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about amines
about amines and these are just organic
compounds where you have a nitrogen
bonded to groups that contain carbon so
if i were to just draw some amines right
here you could have something like this
where you have a nitrogen
bonded to two hydrogens and then maybe
some type of carbon chain maybe it's
just one carbon right here so maybe you
have a carbon which is also bonded to
three hydrogens like this in this case
you would have a primary amine if you
have the nitrogen bonded to two carbons
so if you have something like this a
nitrogen bonded to
two carbons so it has one carbon chain
right there and i'm just drawing methyl
groups here because the chain could just
keep keep on going maybe you have two
like that
and then you have a hydrogen right there
this would be a secondary amine and then
finally you could imagine if you had it
bonded to three it would be a tertiary
amine and this is just to get you
introduced to the terminology
to
the terminology
c
h3 just like that now like all of the
other new groups or new types of
compounds that we've explored what i
want to do is just introduce you to the
naming of it because one that lets you
recognize them when you hear their names
but it also i think on some level
familiarizes you with your structure so
let's let's do a couple of naming
examples i drew these ahead of time and
in general just to remember a means are
pretty high priority group out of all of
the things that we've learned so far the
only thing that is a higher priority is
actually the alcohols or actually the
thiols which i'm not even i don't even
remember if i did a video on it but
thiols are just like alcohols but
instead of an oxygen you have a sulfur
so this comes right after those
so let's think about this one right here
so we always want to look for our
longest carbon chain and our longest
carbon chain is right here one two three
four five six seven carbons you wanna
start numbering it closer to the
functional group one two three
four
five
six
and seven
and then the functional group is on the
two is on the two carbon right there so
first of all seven carbons we would use
the prefix hept so it would be heptan
let me write that down so it would be
heptan
hep
heptan and since our functional group is
an amine in this situation it has higher
pro it has a higher priority than the
fact that this is an alkane so this will
actually define the suffix this will
define the suffix so we would then say
well then on the two carbon
on the let me do this in a new color on
the two carbon right over here we have
the amine group so it's heptan
heptan 2 amine
heptane 2 amine and we're done we know
that we have an amine group on the 2
carbon now let's do this one this one's
a little bit more hairy so first of all
we always want to figure out the longest
carbon chain and it looks like this
this the ring is going to be the longest
carbon chain we have one
two
three four five six
carbons so this thing right here is the
longest chain we only have one two
carbons right there one carbon one
carbon right over there so our our root
our root is going to be
cyclohexane
so our root is going to be cyclohexane i
want to make sure i have enough space
cyclocyclohexane
and then once again it's an amine so
this is going to take higher priority
it's going to so we're not just going to
put an e at the end and call the
cyclohexane this takes higher priority
this takes higher priority so it'll
actually define the suffix so and you
and and another thing to think about is
you could say okay this is going to be
the one this is going to be the one
carbon and so you could call the
cyclohexane one amine but in general if
this is defining it you always assume
that you're going to start numbering at
right there at number one so you could
just call this cyclohexane
amine hexanamine
if it's written like this you assume
that the one carbon is where the amine
group is attached now what else do we
have on this thing we took care of the
amine we took care of the cycle well we
have this ether right here and this
ether has one
two carbons if it was just a two carbon
chain it would be ethane but since we
have it's an ether it's bonded to this
oxygen we call this ethoxy
so that right there is ethoxy
ethoxy and we're going to think about
how we're going to number this so i'll
leave that alone and what are these over
here well this is a methyl group
that's a ch3 implicitly you don't see it
drawn there's a carbon there and
all of if car if carbon is neutral it
has to have four bonds and if you only
draw one of them the other three are
assumed to be the hydrogen so this is a
methyl group
this is a methyl group and then this is
also a methyl group this is also a
methyl group so we have dimethyl
so this is also a methyl group right
over there and when we think about
numbering we could number from one two
three or we could start numbering one
two three and in general you wanna go
numbering in the direction where you hit
the functional group first so we want to
go one
two
three
four
and five so this right here is five
ethoxy this is five ethoxy and then this
is one two dimethyl
these two combined
these two combined you would call this
one comma two
dimethyl
and then when you want to lift list them
in order you the ethoxy would take
precedence in alphabetical because the
dye you shouldn't count in the
alphabetical order you're look really
looking at this is just saying two
methyls so you really just want to look
at the two of whatever you're talking
about m comes after e in alphabetical
order so this is going to be this is
going to be five ethoxy
actually let me just rewrite the whole
thing so this is going to be five ethoxy
five
ethoxy
one two
dimethyl one two
dimethyl
cyclohexanamine
dimethyl cyclo
cyclone
amine
amine and we're done
and we're done this was probably one of
the longest words we've used in naming
but hopefully you see when you break
down the different pieces it actually
makes sense that it represents this
molecule